vous nous donner une belle feuille de
route à nous autres parlementaires
juste avant de poursuivre sur la table
ronde suivante kir et abordera toutes
les questions que vous venez de liste
est un mot très difficile sur les sept
points qu'agnès verdier-molinié vient
d'évoquer devant nous
quel est pour vous le point prioritaire
sur lequel on doit travailler un seul je
suis désolé l'exercice est difficile où
un seul nom le point priori je sais pas
voilà le point prioritaire c'est que la
loi arrête de corseter le dialogue
social dans les entreprises et dans les
branches
je crois que c'est ça le sujet
finalement et tout se résume à peu près
à ça c'est à dire qu'il faut ouvrir des
espaces de négociations sur tous les
sujets qu a indiqué anne lise verdier
molinié avec la petite difficulté dans
pas la grande difficulté qu'il y avait
qu elle a aussi évoqué qui comment on
fait dans les très petites entreprises
il a effectivement il ya la technique du
référendum on peut imaginer tout un tas
de choses mais on ne fera pas l'économie
effectivement de toiletter complètement
la loi c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
laisser le code du travail tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui et simplement dire ah bah on
va essayer d'y déroger par accord
d'entreprise parce que dans les tpe ça
ne marchera pas et monsieur asselin et
bien payé pour savoir ça aussi voilà
donc on fera pas cette économie est vu
par ailleurs on ne peut pas à la fois
rester de rêver avec un code du travail
en 50 articles à ce cas là je suis tout
à fait d'accord fait ce que dit mon
collègue de droite
évidemment ce serait simplement le
gouvernement des juges même si bertrand
martinot même exercice la même
conclusion on pourra pas faire
l'économie de peynier le code du travail
et de le réécrire
mais comme les chateurs aura donc une
responsabilité imminente
je voudrais quand même ici sauvé le
dispositif larcher
car finalement tout le monde veut faire
passer à la trappe le dispositif larcher
je vais quand même rappelé le dispositif
larcher et la déviance du dispositif
larcher c'est qu'en réalité quand le
gouvernement celui là où le prochain
voudra initié une réforme du code du
travail est la démonstration a été faite
il faudra bien par la loi
réformer le code du travail on devra
demander aux partenaires sociaux ce
qu'il souhaite
s'ils veulent négocier négocié
il n'a jamais été écrit dans le
dispositif large et que le gouvernement
est tenu de reprendre ce que les
partenaires sociaux ont écrit c'est une
question de responsabilité
c'est la raison pour laquelle je leur
recommande et j'étais avec monsieur
mailly la semaine dernière et il a dit
oui
un miracle bon il louis pas publiquement
je lui ai dit arrêtez de conclure des
accords simplement dites nous quel est
le chemin que vous voulez suivre et
c'est le gouvernement qui choisira ce
sont les gouvernements qui choisiront
c'est le parlement qui décidera donc
c'est un processus démocratie politique
démocratie sociale qui ne faut pas
abandonner pour la fabrication de la loi
parce que j'allais confère une
légitimité beaucoup plus importantes et
notamment une adaptabilité économique et
social mais ce n'est ni une défausse le
x factor n'a pas se défausser sur les
partenaires sociaux et ça doit pas être
nos cases des partenaires sociaux à
l'égard du pouvoir parlementaire et du
pouvoir gouvernemental donc que chacun
retrouve sa bonne place
ça s'appelle la coopération c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis presque un
fanatique de l'article l e 1 pour
l'avoir poussé à l'époque je regrette
qu'ils vivent cette déviance et ça
rejoint ce que vous disiez nous allons
commencer par ça et nous allons du reste
faire un catalogue encore plus longue
durée ce parce que ça s'arrête pas à
cette réalité là on pourra aller à 50 60
et 10 mai le temps est compté et la
condition sera le courage politique le
dernier mot revient aux chefs
d'entreprise qui étaient présents à la
table ronde pour merci encore et merci à
vous tous
plus c'est dur à la sortie plus c'est
compliqué à l'entrée sécuriser le
licenciement